it's great to welcome back to the
program today democratic congressman
rowe khanna who represents california's
17th district uh it's great to have you
back on and it's you know the last time
you were on was before the russian
invasion of ukraine so i think maybe we
would start there
uh weeks ago there were reports
seemingly credible reports that russia
sort of had the resources for about
another 10 days of what they started
with it's obviously been more than 10
days and what's taking place on the
ground has shifted to some degree
what's your outlook now based on what
you've been briefed on that you can talk
about about what what the longevity of
this might potentially be
well i don't underestimate the russians
uh in fact uh charles lester had sent me
an article he's a
expert on what russia did in syria uh
just reminding us how brutal russia can
be and
they spent almost a
decade in syria
uh where they did in aleppo uh what
they're doing now
to cities in ukraine uh and they've had
the same uh record in georgia so
i admire uh and support uh
unconditionally the ukrainian resistance
but i don't think we should be a rosite
uh in terms of uh
how difficult the this is gonna be and
how uh ruthless russians
there are some uh including to some
degree noam chomsky and others
who have focused on the
what they see as the futility of
resistance against the overwhelming
power of russia and that ukraine should
essentially
give russia some stuff and try to end
hostilities as quickly as possible not a
perspective that many others
there are many others who very much
disagree with that perspective what's
your sense of what ukraine should be
doing
well my job as an american lawmaker is
to support ukraine and to provide make
sure we're providing them with military
weapons which we are make sure that
they're getting the resources that they
need make sure that president zielenski
has the unconditional support of the
united states i think the president has
done a tremendous job with secretary
blinken in rallying nato i have called
out countries like india because i'm the
vice chair of the india caucus saying
we've got to be unified in condemning
putin but i also have said that we have
to at the end of the day having
negotiated settlement and the united
states should be working
towards uh to do whatever we can uh
before that but strengthening ukraine
and having this resistance succeed uh i
think is one step to that because it
weakens putin's hand uh and putin has to
be in a weak position to even accept
some uh compromise i mean zelinski has
floated compromises he has said he's
open uh to
uh
to seeing uh
even not even being neutral in certain
cases but
putin is the one as my understanding
isn't coming to the table
in terms of u.s troops on the ground joe
biden from the beginning said that
that's not something that he's willing
to do
and there's significant
support for that but not
total support for that red line
what's your position on on boots on the
ground
no and the president has been correct he
has been wise he's been restrained
he has done everything he can to support
the ukrainian people
but not get us into a war with russia
i don't think anyone in america will
want that especially when you've got
putin making uh
terribly concerning statements about
using nuclear weapons against great
britain i mean the last thing we want to
do is to get into a
world war
two different things that are touchy to
say the least and if there's anything
you can tell us about them it would be
great one is increased speculation
including after a recent video that
vladimir putin is ill
uh looking swollen gripping a table just
very unhealthy appearance and lots of
speculation about that as a possible
factor in his actions on the other hand
speculation that
there has
without a doubt intelligence experts are
paid to provide all options to elected
officials and that it would be unusual
that the question of could putin be
assassinated would not have come up not
that anyone's planning to do it but that
this is what intelligence people are
paid to do provide every option can you
weigh in at all on either of those two
things
well i certainly not privy to any
knowledge that isn't out there uh in the
american uh public uh
so i i guess first i would just say that
it would be uh absolutely wrong and is
not the united states policy should not
be the united states policy to try to
assassinate a uh sitting head of state
of another country
and uh i would
vigorously oppose uh something like that
and it's nothing that i have
heard of
being planned
and i don't think in any way is the
policy of this administration
the second point about putin's health i
mean i've read about the same
speculation but uh i don't think that
can inform a policy
we have to
be governed by
the basic facts of what we can confirm
and that is that we need to continue to
help the ukrainian people
have as tough a resistance as possible
with the hopes that when putin is
sufficiently pushed back then we can
have a negotiated settlement last
question on this do you aside from what
would be acceptable responses to it
where it's a different question do you
agree with the perspective
that a nato expansion could legitimately
be seen as a form of aggression by putin
i don't think that is the cause of this
war i i think that the cause of this war
is what putin himself has written that
he wanted to see ukraine be part of uh
russia and uh that he views ukraine
historically as uh as part of russia and
that is uh his own words his own
rationale so
we can put aside whether the question on
nato expansion and how much to expand
nato and what that implication has for
u.s security and u.s russian relations
but i don't think it is any anyway the
proximate cause of this war okay so kind
of on that note and into this next topic
there are uh
some on twitter and in sort of lefty
media circles that have sort of turned
on you in the last six months and uh the
idea being rokhana isn't progressive
enough he's too friendly with big tech
he's not willing to say something like
for example no listen i mean nato
expansion if we had something equivalent
going on on our southern border with a
coalition involving other countries we
would absolutely see it as aggression
even if it's not the proximate cause
do you believe that the criticisms of
you are fair do you feel like you've
changed in some way over the last six to
12 months that there's more sort of like
anti-rochana sentiment happening in some
of the usual places on the internet
i don't know do you think there is i
don't i i haven't since that i know we
had a big i had a
big disagreement uh with i think max
blumenthal because i basically support
the president's policy uh on ukraine and
there have been people who've been
critical uh that i haven't uh
sort of
moral equivalence
between america and russia but i i don't
see that i think putin is a dictator who
is violating territorial sovereignty and
is
clearly in the wrong here and that he
has to be resisted uh and i know there's
some people who are more sympathetic
to putin's perspective uh on uh
in max blumenthal's perspective i just
philosophically
disagree with that strongly disagree
with that and i'm much more on joe
biden's side than max blumenthal's side
and i guess maybe that has
led to some
progressives being upset and i guess the
only other thing i've noticed that some
folks are upset is that i'm speaking
with senator manchin about trying to get
a climate deal
look i've been for the boldest vision on
climate uh i shared the big oil hearings
i've
exposed a lot of their disinformation
for the last 40 years but i care so much
about the climate that i want to get
something done before the midterms and
you know if talking to to uh
senator uh
mansion uh
is unacceptable then basically people
are saying let's throw up our hands and
not get a climate deal that's not
acceptable to me yeah it seems to be
this debate that's not new about
pragmatism versus idealism which is
it seems in doing some research before
talking to you today that some of the
disappointment for lack of a better term
is that some feel that
what was previously a much stronger
alignment with someone like bernie
sanders has shifted into being much more
accepting of the status quo and maybe
the mansion stuff is being perceived by
some
as being too accepting of the status quo
whereas it sounds like you see it as
being a realist and a pragmatist because
that's who you have to negotiate with
and work with right now
yeah and i look i've always been a
pragmatic progressive i've always been a
progressive capitalist i used to get
criticized when i was a bernie's
campaign as a co-chair uh
people saying oh why why are you making
this uh argument about how bernie is
an fdr and actually a progressive
capitalist
capitalists
why are you not uh being more
confrontational but i guess i haven't
changed i think people's maybe
perceptions uh they're getting to know
who i really am and that is someone who
believes in medicare for all and has
fought for it free public college and
has fought for canceling student loans i
was just out in a rally and actually
publishing an op-ed in the post tomorrow
on it uh someone who's fought on yemen
against wars overseas but also someone
who believes in innovation believes in
entrepreneurship believes that
ultimately you you do have value in a
free enterprise system if it can be fair
with healthcare and education for
everyone and someone who's pragmatic who
wants to take the progressive movement
and say okay we gotta now get to the 50
mark so that we can get policy done uh
that's just one messaging so i think
describing me as a a pragmatic
progressive and someone who is a hundred
percent committed to the policies but a
more of a coalition building a little
bit more aspirational uh would be
accurate and and that may not be
uh
appeal to everyone no politician can but
it is who i am and i would say it's been
consistent in how i have been since i've
been in congress
so let's talk about 2022 you and your
434 colleagues are up for re-election as
is always the case every two years we
also have some important governor's
races a third of the senate is up for
re-election elizabeth warren recently
wrote a piece where she says it's really
not looking good for democrats i tend to
agree
i am particularly worried because i look
at some of these races for example
monday in the pennsylvania senate race
to pick one yeah there was the
democratic debate where you have john
fetterman uh and conor lamb and malcolm
kenyatta and a woman whose last name i
believe is khalil but i don't remember
right now on the democratic side on the
republican side you had this television
doctor mehmet oz as well as dave
mccormick and others in looking at it i
love fetterman on policy
his debate was i would call it
disastrous in terms of presentation and
when i look at it i didn't i didn't
follow it i mean i yeah all the bernie
folks like him
i like him on policy but when i looked
at the five republicans some of whom are
bonkers i mean they're out of this world
nuts it looks like any of the five would
do better in debates against the four
democrats that are running and michael
oh sir
what do i need to learn for the future
he seemed disoriented to be perfectly
frank he seemed unprepared and and
confused at different times it was weird
i mean i would recommend that you watch
it but the greater point given that you
didn't didn't watch that in particular
is
i'm very worried that as terrible and
dangerous as some of the republican
candidates are
that the democratic party is is just not
prepared for what may be coming in
november and that it's going to be
absolutely brutal i mean what's your
outlook on the way it's looking right
now
it's a tough election and i think there
are two things we need to do one what
elizabeth warren has said forgive the
student loan pass something on climate
to excite your own base but i think it's
beyond that david and i uh again i don't
know people
everyone all agree with me but here's
what i think you know i was born in
philadelphia in 1976 our bicycle i still
believe this is the greatest country in
the world there are millions of people
who want to come to america and not go
to china i think democrats have to start
with that and then we need to say
there's a problem half this country was
de-industrialized the jobs were shipped
to china they were shipped to mexico and
50 percent of this country isn't
participating in the wealth generation
and producing things uh while districts
like mine have wealth piling up and have
been vetting benefiting from
globalization so we understand why
people are angry we understand why they
keep voting uh folks out but we have a
concrete plan to bring good jobs to have
reindustrialization to bring economic
prosperity to these communities and
we're going to start to do it concretely
just like bobby kennedy did at bedford
stuyvesant in 1964 bringing business
community labor together and actually
showing results and i think we've got it
if we lead with that economic message of
economic revitalization look at the
numbers today with the gdp uh going down
uh in the quarter it's all because we're
importing things it's all because of the
trade deficit why can't the democratic
party become the party of
reindustralization economic
revitalization
that to me is a
not just a winning message it's a true
message and it gives us the best shot uh
in i think winning back some of these
places well two two thoughts on that one
it's notably missing from the discussion
about reindustrializing and bringing
supply chains back home and both
republicans and democrats talk about it
we're going to do made in the usa trump
says it at every rally joe biden's been
saying it it's missing from that that
that will make stuff products
significantly more expensive and as an
economy over 30 years cumulatively
the us has opted for
cheaper stuff that's produced outside
the country we kind of have to deal with
the reality that everything would be
much more expensive if we brought all
supply chains back home wouldn't we
not necessarily david look i mean well
there are two points i mean yes it may
be more expensive instead of having
everything be made by
slave labor conditions in china and
cheap imports but the other possibility
is that we just massively increase
productivity in this country we
massively increase uh our
capacity to industrialize and grow and
that's what we haven't done you know
trump talks about it but he's not
actually articulating a industrial
policy of actually having the government
be providing purchase agreements and
loans in a massive scale with private
industry to bring production back
and i think biden we were doing it with
the competes act until putting 20
billion dollars in ohio but we could be
doing a lot more so
are you saying if there are two
alternatives which is okay get all the
cheap imports from china with slave
labor yeah that's always going to be
cheaper
than
building productive capacity in the
united states but building more
productivity and productive capacity in
the united states can also be
de-inflationary it'll be less
de-inflationary than just offshoring the
china but i would argue that most
americans would pick the round of
increasing our productivity instead of
importing from china both for national
security reasons and because of moral
reasons of having dignity of basic
workers are treated
so last thing on this and for today uh
on on the economic message i recently
watched a great netflix docu-series
about bobby kennedy and the economic
message worked extraordinarily well um
in his campaign cut too short right in
uh
in his era
he wasn't up against a republican party
that had very successfully weaponized
imaginary cultural issues critical race
theory
uh textbooks uh dr seuss uh you know
disney all all these different things
the woke mind virus and all of these
things
it's not feeling like the economic
message is um smothering these culture
battles that the right has created and
is fighting so what what should be done
i i just don't see the message getting
through
but has to be an economic message linked
with american patriotism linked with a
hope and belief in the american story
when i i've gone to places like
paintsville kentucky beckley west
virginia galesburg illinois
in places like the west side of chicago
where manufacturing has left black
manufacturing is left and i talk about
my story my hope of america in my view
that uh communities need to have uh the
economic opportunity uh for like kids in
my district have now it tends to break
through now i will grant this i'm
relatively unknown and so i haven't had
millions of dollars spent against me
making me a boogeyman
and maybe if i did it would be harder
than being relatively unknown but even
people who have more baggage i think if
you show up to these communities if you
actually are delivering something in
these communities and if you start with
i believe in america i believe we're a
good decent people i believe we are
going to remain the greatest country in
the world just every democrat may want
to start if they believe it i mean with
that paragraph and i think it puts
people at ease right now i think so many
people are wondering whether we
are judging them you know there was a
focus group in pennsylvania they said
republicans are crazy democrats are
preaching
we have to get a sense where we can
connect with people and say look we have
a real vision and all those other things
are distractions that's not going to
help your kids get a better life it's
not going to help us speak china we have
a real plan and we got to hammer them
talk about that again and again and
again and not get sidetracked uh
as they're trying to have us make do i
think it can work i do am i 100
confident no i mean that's why they have
elections yeah yeah no and the
difficulty is when those other issues
are meant to make people afraid that's
the basis of reactionary politics it can
be hard for the sober but positive
economic message to shine through but i
think that's exactly the challenge that
uh that that you're talking about uh
congressman ro khanna uh from california
17th district always great speaking with
you
thank you always enjoy